hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the most terrifying
pony filled adventure that you will find
this side of the Mississippi don't know
about the other side of the Mississippi
but on this side this damn terrifying
the derring-do book no other copies of a
book with that title and publisher have
been found and no record of the bubble
through exists I don't even know what
that is daring do and the girl sapphires
- what I can't even read what that says
it's all gibberish did readers of the
book seem to exhibit symptoms of any
redacted they read about the effect can
take between blue and human our stupor
data expunged I don't know what that is
if that's another SCP in the game oh no
I don't know all right I'm still in my
eternal quest to find gate B ooh that
guy's head is on backwards oh well that
sucks for him where am i oh wait no I'm
right outside here oh that's right I
need to go find the gate because I
haven't gotten there yet that's right I
remember okay I'm sorry I apologize for
being stupid hello buddy
see here okay I went this way but I
don't remember going too far because I
remember turning around before I thought
hey they got a little pony stack party
going on in there well I want to find
that I want to go in there hello are you
trapped in here mister be charming they
didn't shoot me wait they didn't shoot
me I thought they were gonna shoot me I
thought that was supposed to be the pony
equivalent of the villain of the Velva
STG the super task force whatever would
you mccall it I don't really remember
anyway
ah ah yes I gotta get out here remote
detonation of alpha warheads turn both
of those off and let's get out here it
was way too close
put on your gas mask and let's go go go
where's the button where's the button
where's the button
ah yes oh um ska got my ball prevent ah
come on
where was the button where was elevator
button that's not cool
yeah whatever it was only a matter of
time before I'd have to deal with this
[ __ ] is saving here you know I didn't
know I honestly didn't know about the
noclipping function until I read it in
the comments in the last video if I
hadn't done that I could noclip long
time ago I would have oh shut up you
dumb stupid pony god totally wait is
this going to the same place yet it's
okay there's this area in here that I
still don't know what this is all about
but apparently it's has to do with some
changes and this one I some changes to I
don't know
radical Ares dimension his throne room
is over there some weird pension gentle
them pendulums are over here and I don't
know what's going on but I can barely
see and then the pudendal UM's are
swinging but I don't really care I'm
just moving forward ow that hurt ah come
on I thought I could oh I thought that
let me out didn't that let me out before
maybe not I don't know I don't know I
don't know where I'm going I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know why any of
this is happening why me
let's go this goes to the exact a.m.
same place right I think they all do
must be part of the mod stupid Rainbow
Dash if that is your real name
Oh smash
something's happening I don't see what
though well that came close to my face
ah ah that was really good oh there was
that a blink thought that was actually
something going by my face ah
that was our guy about my mice I made it
where did I make it
oh you gotta be [ __ ] me bull uh-huh
Cupid rainbows get out of here let me
out I want to go home
Oh wha Oh
oh this looks familiar I got out so
easily last time why why why why why why
why are you all like so [ __ ] on me now
huh can I get out can I get home please
I got stuff to do you I got stuff to do
I got stuff to do what I'll piss you did
it again I can't even tell anymore
because everything's so Technicolor as I
recall I need to just make this circuit
three times and he'll let me out I don't
know just shut up radical rainbows haze
Dagenham radical rainbows I don't really
know I don't know who knows I have no
idea I just want to go home well I mean
my home is a containment facility so I'm
not exactly sure where my home is or
what I'm doing Oh
poby I'm going backwards I read there's
one oh there it is I can't believe I
haven't done the note yet okay now we
can move forward ding okay we're Ono
noclip is that a thing how do I know
clip-on aha
so if I do that and this means I can fly
upwards
upwards it doesn't help me because I
don't know where I am
it's our help I'm floating in darkness I
can't even see the fudge magnets oh
what's that
what's it aha I see this okay so this is
the pillars of creation here and if I go
down
ah-huh ah-huh ah-huh what was that oh
this is the other side okay so I just
got to go here and then I'll turn noclip
off ya know clip off boom yes oh yes get
away get away radical Larry oh come on
let me out want to go home
want to go home this is not helping me
in my query access violation Fajr okay
all right we're back in it to win it
we're being stalked by what's-his-face
rainbow radical radical rainbow Larry
radical rainbows Vicki where are we now
walls
go away radical Rambo I don't have time
to deal with your bull there we go ah
finally okay we got it okay now and I
had the gas mask on the whole time I
didn't even think about turning that off
okay whatever does this go I'm gonna
contain this son of a mobile task force
the facility all remaining survivors are
advised to stay in evacuation shelter or
any safe area until the unit has secured
the facility start escorting personnel
out when the escape LTS have been
contained um I don't think that's gonna
happen anyway let's use the Boosh loft
just me please
Oh No
where is he there is I was about to say
man oh dang in a while alright yeah suck
it unfortunate guy stuck in that
containment thing brah trap you and
sound go off yay contain what oh no no
no no no no no no no what the hell is
that
Oh sunny comes out of nowhere by me late
ah [ __ ] you oh it's out of a [ __ ]
princess molestia secret porn step I
remember reading that before still funny
still funny
princess molest [ __ ] is that actually a
pony name god I hope so
that would be so damn funny probably not
I doubt it that's it when the object is
finally through with testing it is to be
destroyed immediately for us of the
royal family to avoid any slander
political reputation tarnished why would
they want to test the porn stash these
weirdos oh no I didn't say what I was
out
this whole episode sucks it's all
episode just sucks balls
Oh episode just suck so bad oh this is
to his throne room
Oh God screw you
where is he I can't even I've the gas
mask on that much better
hey guess what go [ __ ] yourself
that's what yeah ah what are you you're
just a pair of eyes you're nothing
you're nothing you dick you're paralyzed
boney eyes or some you're an a-hole
you know what days that's you you're
just aa honey duh hey Ann I got a how do
I wait teleport what I don't know the
room names Oh home tough teleport
scp-173 spawn pinky yeah he'll show me
ow
just happened even though the changeling
army huh yeah yeah there's got to be
something that can help me wireframe on
oh god no wireframe off status oh that's
a lot of statuses diseases as it as it
is is it oh ok room pocket dimension I
gotta get out of here
room off this earth nope no fu teleport
office yeah oh [ __ ] it work uh wireframe
ah yeah I made it out totes mix croats
legitimately now let's take this off and
bask in our own magnet oh [ __ ] I'm I'm
Way behind cuz that's gone now stop Lee
bright in here
I just remembered I'm still playing a
game here you go to hell and you die
[ __ ] where am i where am i ah what the
hell
I brush in me going through the facility
backwards oh no I'm back at the
beginning yeah
teleport gate be strong
gave me all you need to shut up for 10
seconds I'm trying to I'm trying to
handle the situation it is not going
very well for me going backwards again
which is not smart let's close this and
turn around all right we okay okay okay
all right top this come on we got to do
something here gotta do something ah I'm
such an a-hole that's it
alright okay haha done panicking think I
just gotta find a PA this game is it I
like it where have you come from
how are you oh well come from magical
ponies boat is everywhere friendship is
magic
ah crying like a baby
where does it come from just kill me oh
oh no oh no no clip-on go up I think I
think I'm going up maybe I don't know
where I am now
ah piss let's just teleport office -
maybe maybe though Turk
yeah pissed teleport office oh my no
clip is on so that's probably uh-huh
there we go okay I'm back to where I was
oh god it's going terribly this is going
just awfully come on let's go um let's
go uh let's go again but this time less
stupidly this not F up so badly
wasn't that a dead end anyway over there
I probably got to go down here sit in
the [ __ ] alright I see you I see you
good hell and ah hi go to hell and die
good hell and I go hello gun good Hilda
hey I see your ass stick another go away
go away go away
hahahaha who's the man I am Oggy
yeah you go skitter around back there
and then you go to hell and you die
go to hell and die go to hell and die oh
it's nice and dark not you I almost
contained you rainbow - that's still
freaky [ __ ] dude drink drink filling
think doing doing doing but it's a I
mean it's not really a threat I wish it
was like um like there was up a picture
oh hey ah piss and ah piss
no that's oh you son of a get out of
there you son of a [ __ ] oh this is
doctor mootness whose mood to us I don't
know whatever it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I gotta go down the
maintenance tell it because I didn't
frickin can I'm you know what that's
locked I'm done for now I'm done I must
go down apparently I'm not done yet
I'm not done yet
you're not you're not ready to be down
here I got a super run hmm you're not
supposed to be down here that's not fair
that's not part of the rules it's upper
rules girls Oh
come up come up come up please please
please Josh josh Josh huh go up elevator
this is an act you know what screw this
screw this
I'll do it myself do it myself
ah so Kelly where's the other party
where's the exit where's the exit
I don't see where the exit is whoa whoa
this is not it's not how this is
supposed to work where where did I end
up okay there's the elevator that's the
top of the elevator right yeah
no no that's not that's just that's more
hallway okay there's the elevator okay I
got it
then the elevators posed to be straight
up I went straight up I would wait I
don't know I don't know I'm so confused
I got a headache there we go okay now
it's working okay we got it unless I
just went back into the same one that I
came out of before which B I'll get good
it's different
oh I'm done now okay I've done I'm done
haha oh damn ponies god damn ponies
everywhere - Deb Pony okay so I'm all
done here so thank you all so much for
watching click the interfaces more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
ah
up here
Oh